Nanna Wadding is a suburb just outside of the main city area of Melbourne, in the state of Victoria. It was 11.30am, Thursday the 27th of March 1986, and Harris Avenue in Nanna Wadding presented a problem for the police surveillance team following the red jaguar. There was a small dead end street, no way to observe the house their bank robbery suspect was heading to without them being obvious. To avoid being detected they had no choice but to let the suspect out of their sight. It was only one way in and one way out of Harris Avenue, so the suspect would have to
纳纳瓦丁是维多利亚州墨尔本市中心区域外的一个郊区。1986年3月27日星期四上午11点30分，纳纳瓦丁的哈里斯大道给跟踪那辆红色捷豹的警方监视小组带来了一个难题。那是一条狭窄的死胡同，他们无法在不被发现的情况下监视嫌疑人前往的房子。为了避免被发现，他们别无选择，只能让嫌疑人脱离视线。哈里斯大道只有一条进出通道，所以嫌疑人最终必须
come back past them eventually. No big deal they thought, as they parked outside Harris Avenue, keeping a close eye out for the red jaguar. When the 1979 model Holden Commodore drove out of the street, the police weren't to know their suspect was inside. They were looking for a red jaguar, not a Commodore. It was a stroke of luck for the suspect, he had no idea the police were watching him. The change of cars had nothing to do with avoiding the police tail.
经过他们返回。他们认为这没什么大不了的，于是把车停在哈里斯大道外，密切注视着那辆红色捷豹。当那辆1979款的霍顿准将轿车从街上开出来时，警察并不知道嫌疑人就在车里。他们要找的是一辆红色捷豹，而不是一辆准将。这对嫌疑人来说是走运，他根本不知道警察在监视他。换车与躲避警察的跟踪毫无关系。
There was a far more sinister reason for the switch. Back in 1986, the Victorian Police Headquarters building was located on the corner of Russell Street and La Trobe Street in Melbourne. Opened in 1943, the building was recognised as a symbol of policing in Victoria and was referred to by many officers simply as Russell Street. The building housed many different police units and hundreds of officers were based there. At 12.50pm that same day, Thursday the 27th of March 1986, Officer Charles Bazina from
这次换车有着更险恶的原因。1986年，维多利亚州警察总部大楼位于墨尔本罗素街和拉特罗布街的拐角处。该建筑于1943年启用，被公认为维多利亚州警务的象征，许多警官干脆称其为“罗素街”。大楼里设有许多不同的警察部门，数百名警官在那里办公。当天，也就是1986年3月27日星期四下午12点50分，来自
the drug squad parked his unmarked police car on Russell Street, directly outside of headquarters. He was annoyed at the car parked in front of him, a two-tone Holden Commodore sedan, the same one that had driven out of Harris Avenue past police surveillance teams a short while earlier. Bazina knew it wasn't a police car, but it was parked in the police parking spot. He had a quick look through the window, there was no one inside and he couldn't see anything to be worried about.
缉毒组的查尔斯·巴齐纳警官将他的便衣警车停在罗素街，就在总部大楼外。他对停在前面的一辆双色霍顿准将轿车感到恼火，那正是刚才从哈里斯大道开出并经过警方监视小组的那辆车。巴齐纳知道那不是警车，但它却停在警察的停车位上。他透过车窗快速看了一眼，里面没有人，他也看不出有什么可疑之处。
He didn't have time to deal with the illegal park, he forgot about it and made his way inside headquarters. Directly across the road from the Police Headquarters building was Melbourne Magistrates Court. Constable Carl DiNardio was a young 19-year-old officer fresh out of the academy. He was assigned to court security at the time, which basically meant he sat up the back of the courtroom and made sure no one caused any trouble. It was a slow day and DiNardio was happy when the court broke for lunch. He made his way out of the court building and onto Russell Street just before 1pm.
他没时间处理违章停车，便不再理会，径直走进总部。在警察总部大楼的马路对面是墨尔本治安法院。卡尔·迪纳迪奥警员是一名刚从警校毕业的19岁年轻警官。当时他被分配到法院安保部门，基本上就是坐在法庭后排，确保没人闹事。那天没什么事，法庭休庭吃午饭时，迪纳迪奥很高兴。下午1点前，他走出法院大楼，来到罗素街。
As DiNardio was walking out of the court, 21-year-old Constable Angela Taylor was flipping a coin with her partner. They were working in the watch house that day, which is the police cells next to the court and they were also on a lunch break. Angela Taylor graduated from the police academy at the top of her class and was described as a brilliant and vibrant person with a magnificent career ahead of her. The loser of the coin toss had to go on by lunch. Angela lost the toss and made her way onto Russell Street, heading across the road to
当迪纳迪奥走出法院时，21岁的安吉拉·泰勒警员正在和搭档抛硬币。他们那天在看守所工作，也就是法院旁边的警察拘留室，他们当时也在午休。安吉拉·泰勒以优异的成绩从警校毕业，被描述为一个聪明、充满活力、前途无量的人。抛硬币输的人要去买午餐。安吉拉输了，她走向罗素街，穿过马路前往
the canteen inside Police Headquarters. The quickest way to the canteen was through the southern entrance and that's where Angela Taylor headed. DiNardio was headed for the canteen as well, but he wasn't as familiar with the layout of headquarters being fresh out of the academy, so he made his way to the northern entrance. DiNardio and Taylor headed for the same place, but were walking in opposite directions. They didn't bat an eye late as they passed the Holden Commodore Park in the police parking. Drone into a scene of mass panic by the blast, the first explosion went off just before one
警察总部内的食堂。去食堂最快的路是经过南门，安吉拉·泰勒就是往那边走的。迪纳迪奥也要去食堂，但他刚从警校毕业，对总部的布局不太熟悉，所以他走向了北门。迪纳迪奥和泰勒要去同一个地方，但走的是相反的方向。他们经过停在警察停车位上的那辆霍顿准将时，连眼皮都没抬一下。爆炸引发了大规模恐慌，第一次爆炸发生在下午一点前，
o'clock when a car blew up outside the police headquarters. Eyewitness news cameras were first on the scene. Just a few minutes ago, a car bomb exploded outside the police station here in Russell Street. There was a sound of one massive explosion. We were sitting in our office, our eyewitness news office just around the corner. The glass was shattered in the windows of our office. After that, there were several more explosions, the sound of properly fueling the car exploding.
当时一辆汽车在警察总部外爆炸。目击者新闻摄像机最先赶到现场。“就在几分钟前，罗素街的警察局外发生了一起汽车炸弹爆炸。听到了一声巨大的爆炸声。我们当时坐在办公室里，我们的目击者新闻办公室就在拐角处。办公室窗户的玻璃都被震碎了。在那之后，又发生了几次爆炸，那是汽车燃料爆炸的声音。”
Russell Street was in a complete state of chaos for seconds. Russell Street was in a state of chaos. Policemen, policewomen were screaming. Everybody was in a state of complete hysteria. Nineteen people in the busy lunchtime crowd were injured. Two police officers and a passerby are in a serious condition. Three cars were destroyed in the six explosions. There was massive damage to nearby buildings.
罗素街在几秒钟内陷入了一片混乱。罗素街陷入了混乱。男警察和女警察在尖叫。每个人都处于极度歇斯底里的状态。繁忙的午餐人群中有19人受伤。两名警官和一名路人伤势严重。六次爆炸摧毁了三辆汽车。附近的建筑物受到了严重破坏。
Russell Street was covered in a thick cloud of black smoke. The Holden Commodore, which police referred to as the bomb car, as I will now call it, had been packed with 12 kilograms or 26 pounds of jellignite. Three quarters of it was in the boot, and the rest was in the centre console. A small crater had been left in the road, underneath where it was parked. The crater was 15 centimetres deep and one and a half metres wide, which equals six inches deep and five feet wide. The explosion was extremely powerful, shaking the foundations of the police headquarters
罗素街被浓厚的黑烟笼罩。那辆霍顿准将，也就是警方所说的“炸弹车”，被装上了12公斤（26磅）的胶质炸药。其中四分之三在后备箱里，其余的在中央控制台。车停的地方路面上留下了一个小坑。坑深15厘米，宽1.5米（深6英寸，宽5英尺）。爆炸威力极大，震动了警察总部
building and other buildings nearby, as well as shattering a heap of windows. The force of the blast sent Constable Donatio flying back 15 metres in the air. He suffered a severe wound to his leg, where he was hit with a piece of shrapnel. It completely sliced through his muscle down to the bone, and it was bleeding heavily. He couldn't walk, but he managed to crawl off the road where he was assisted by two fellow officers. One of them used her shirt to tie Torna K around his leg to try and stop the bleeding. One of his kidneys had been sliced by the shrapnel, and his lung was also punctured,
大楼和附近其他建筑的根基，并震碎了大量的窗户。爆炸的冲击力将迪纳迪奥警员抛向空中，飞出15米远。他的腿部受了重伤，被一块弹片击中。弹片完全切开了他的肌肉，直达骨头，流血不止。他无法行走，但设法爬离了马路，两名同事上前协助。其中一人用衬衫做止血带绑在他的腿上，试图止血。他的一个肾脏被弹片切开，肺部也被刺穿，
making it difficult for him to breathe. He had also been struck with a number of smaller shrapnel pieces, all over his body. He required emergency surgery that night. Constable Angela Taylor was closer to the explosion and was caught in the inferno. She suffered horrific burns, 70-80% of her body. Many people tried to do the best they could to help her, but she soon lost consciousness. Magistrate Ian West, who was walking out of the court at the time of the explosion, was also struck with shrapnel and was badly wounded.
导致他呼吸困难。他的全身还被许多较小的弹片击中。当晚他接受了紧急手术。安吉拉·泰勒警员离爆炸点更近，被困在火海中。她遭受了可怕的烧伤，全身70-80%的皮肤受损。许多人尽力帮助她，但她很快失去了知觉。爆炸发生时正走出法院的伊恩·韦斯特法官也被弹片击中，受了重伤。
There were around 20 people injured in total, half of whom were police officers. Constable Angela Taylor was the most critical, but Constable Carl Donatio was in a bad way as well. Ambulance officers arrived on the scene quickly and conveyed the injured to Royal Melbourne Hospital. The busy city street now resembled a war zone. Injured people scattered along the ground everywhere. There was debris and smashed glass all over the street, confusion, panic and people screaming
总共有约20人受伤，其中一半是警察。安吉拉·泰勒警员伤势最重，但卡尔·迪纳迪奥警员的情况也很糟糕。救护人员迅速赶到现场，将伤者送往皇家墨尔本医院。繁忙的城市街道现在看起来像个战区。伤者散落在地，到处都是。街上到处是碎片和碎玻璃，混乱、恐慌和人们的尖叫声
for help. I was standing out in Mackenzie Street just around the corner from Russell when the first explosion hit. Like an earth tremor, the buildings shook and the windows all around us shattered. As we rushed onto the street, debris started flying all over the place, almost hitting most of us. The first thing we saw were people pouring out of the buildings. There was one woman strained off with bleeding legs.
此起彼伏。第一次爆炸发生时，我正站在罗素街拐角处的麦肯齐街上。就像地震一样，建筑物摇晃，我们周围的窗户全部震碎。当我们冲向街道时，碎片开始四处飞溅，差点砸中我们大多数人。我们看到的第一件事就是人们从建筑物里涌出来。有一名妇女腿部流血，被拖了出来。
The crowds seemed to gather from nowhere, but they were being pushed further and further back. The special operations group people moved in. Every car was a potential bomb and they had to check them all. Everybody was being pushed further and further away out into the city street. Police headquarters happened to be where the Victorian Police Special Operations Group were based. Pretty much the same as SWAT, which you might be more familiar with.
人群似乎从四面八方聚集而来，但他们被不断地向后推。特别行动小组的人员进场了。每一辆车都可能是潜在的炸弹，他们必须逐一检查。所有人都被推得越来越远，退到了城市街道上。警察总部恰好是维多利亚州警察特别行动小组的驻地。这和你们可能更熟悉的特警队（SWAT）差不多。
They quickly responded to the carnage on Russell Street, helping to secure the area and carry the injured away from the blast zone. For these officers and the other officers who were assisting, the threat of a second bomb was firmly in their minds. It's a common tactic for a smaller explosion to go off, which attracts a lot of people into the area to help, only then for a second, larger explosion to go off, maximising near the amount of casualties. What happened in the Russell Street bombing was that it didn't go off as planned.
他们迅速响应罗素街的惨状，协助封锁区域并将伤者从爆炸区抬走。对于这些警官和其他协助的警官来说，第二次爆炸的威胁始终萦绕在心头。这是一种常见的战术：先发生一次较小的爆炸，吸引大量人员到现场救援，然后再发生第二次更大的爆炸，从而最大限度地增加伤亡人数。罗素街爆炸案中发生的情况是，它没有按计划进行。
When the primary explosion went from the boot, where most of the Gellignite was, this disrupted the secondary explosion in the centre console, where the rest of the Gellignite was. And as a result, that Gellignite in the centre console hardly exploded at all. So the bomb didn't go off to its full potential. This meant there were still live detonators and sticks of Gellignite present. And the bomb car was up in flames. Firefighters weren't all that keen on approaching the vehicle to put the flames out. That job was left to senior Constable Dennis Tipping from the Special Operations Group.
当主要爆炸从装有大部分胶质炸药的后备箱发生时，这破坏了中央控制台的二次爆炸，那里装有剩余的胶质炸药。结果，中央控制台里的胶质炸药几乎没有爆炸。所以炸弹没有发挥出全部威力。这意味着现场仍然有未引爆的雷管和胶质炸药棒。而且炸弹车已经起火。消防员不太愿意靠近车辆去扑灭火焰。这项工作留给了特别行动小组的高级警员丹尼斯·蒂平。
He put on a bomb suit and managed to get close enough to put out the flames safely. The area was completely shut down and evacuated, creating traffic chaos throughout the city. A thorough search was conducted of other vehicles and buildings in the area to see if there were any other bombs. None were found. Such was the force of the explosion. Debris was found several blocks away. A tyre from the bomb car was found in the rear car park of police headquarters, meaning
他穿上防爆服，设法靠近并安全地扑灭了火焰。该区域被完全封锁并进行了疏散，导致整个城市交通混乱。警方对该地区的其他车辆和建筑物进行了彻底搜查，看是否还有其他炸弹。结果一无所获。爆炸威力之大，碎片在几个街区外都被发现。炸弹车的一个轮胎在警察总部后方的停车场被发现，这意味着
it had been blown over the roof. Well, there were three cars parked across the road, and then there was this almighty explosion, and one of the cars just burst into flame and shelled us with sort of debris and everything else. And with that it sort of threw us against the wall and down onto the ground. I think one of the guards of the car came down on top of Jenny's head, so he hit the wall and bounced off from the gash door shoulder and that. And Jay was wandering around, he hit the ground, so he threw him to the ground.
它被炸飞过了屋顶。“嗯，马路对面停着三辆车，然后就发生了那声巨大的爆炸，其中一辆车突然起火，向我们喷射碎片和其他东西。爆炸把我们撞向墙壁，摔倒在地上。我想车的一个护板掉在了珍妮的头上，所以他撞到墙上又弹开了，伤到了肩膀。杰伊当时在四处走动，他被震倒在地，所以他把他扔到了地上。”
I don't know, it's just like a big fireball. Oh, I heard this big explosion. So I just automatically ran outside to see what was happening. And what about you? Well, I was facing the window and I heard the huge explosion and the window just shook, the glass panel just moved, and it was just like a gas explosion. And how frightened were you? Very frightened.
“我不知道，就像一个巨大的火球。哦，我听到了巨大的爆炸声。所以我自动跑出去看发生了什么。”“那你呢？”“嗯，我当时正对着窗户，听到了巨大的爆炸声，窗户震动了，玻璃板移动了，就像煤气爆炸一样。”“你当时有多害怕？”“非常害怕。”
It was a very powerful explosion. Numerous crime scene officers attended, and bomb experts from the defence department were also called in to help. They quickly found the first big clue, a piece of wood with the remains of an alarm clock attached. There was another piece of metal connected to the alarm clock which helped make up the circuit, but the piece of metal couldn't be identified at that time. The piece of wood looked like it had been cut from a fence post.
这是一次威力巨大的爆炸。多名犯罪现场调查员赶到现场，国防部的炸弹专家也被召集来协助。他们很快发现了第一个重要线索：一块木板，上面附着着一个闹钟的残骸。闹钟上还连接着另一块金属片，有助于构成电路，但那块金属片当时无法识别。那块木板看起来像是从栅栏柱上锯下来的。
The alarm clock was the timing device. When the alarm sounded, a metal piece at the back of the clock clicked over and connected with wires which completed the circuit and set off the bomb. The bomb was found to be poorly constructed. An amateur job, definitely not made by an expert. But it was designed to inflict maximum damage. The bomb maker had packed a large amount of metal tools and sockets around the bomb to act as extra shrapnel.
闹钟是定时装置。当闹钟响起时，闹钟背面的金属片会拨动并与电线连接，从而接通电路并引爆炸弹。经查，该炸弹制作粗糙。绝对是业余水平，不是专家制作的。但它的设计目的是造成最大程度的破坏。炸弹制造者在炸弹周围塞满了大量的金属工具和套筒，作为额外的弹片。
In total, 50 sticks of jellignite were used. If the bomb had gone off to its full potential, it was believed that part of the police headquarters building would have come down. Some thought it may have been an attack against the court. Maybe somebody who was pissed off with a court ruling and was taking revenge. Of course, this had happened before in Australia. It was actually still very fresh in everybody's minds. But perhaps the largest chapter written in Australia's history of outrages concerns the family court
总共使用了50根胶质炸药。如果炸弹发挥了全部威力，据信警察总部大楼的一部分将会倒塌。有人认为这可能是针对法院的袭击。也许是有人对法院的判决不满，正在进行报复。当然，这种情况在澳大利亚以前也发生过。它在每个人的脑海中仍然记忆犹新。但也许澳大利亚历史上关于暴行的最大篇章涉及家庭法院
and family court judges. The first Judge David Opus, gun to death outside his Wallara home in June 1980. Then Justice Richard G, whose bell rose home was blown apart in early March 1984. The Parramatta family law court was badly damaged by a bomb blast in the following month. And then in July 1984, possibly the worst of the family law court attacks. The wife of 61 year old family court judge Justice Ray Watson was killed. The family's Greenwich apartment was shaken to the foundations by a bomb triggered to explode as the front door was opened. Although a member of our family law judiciary had been the target, his wife became the innocent victim.
和家庭法院法官。第一位是戴维·奥普斯法官，1980年6月在他位于瓦拉拉的家中被枪杀。随后是理查德·G法官，他位于贝尔罗斯的家在1984年3月初被炸毁。帕拉马塔家庭法庭在次月被炸弹严重损坏。然后是1984年7月，可能是最严重的家庭法庭袭击事件。61岁的家庭法庭法官雷·沃森的妻子被杀。当房门被打开时，触发的炸弹将这家人位于格林威治的公寓震得地基动摇。虽然目标是我们的家庭法庭司法人员，但他的妻子成了无辜的受害者。
But today's attack, although not an isolated incident, stands out as this city's first senseless terrorist action directed at the public at large. Not yet the streets of Beirut, but a big step closer to the madness. That madness that we thought lurked only beyond our shores. The Russell Street bombing and family law court bombings were not considered linked by police. But consideration was given that the court may have been the target. The court lists were checked and recent decisions were reviewed, but nothing stood out. Others thought that maybe it was a terrorist attack, saying that Beirut had now come to Australia. A comparison made due to the Lebanese civil war that was going on at the time, where there were a lot of bombings.
但今天的袭击，虽然不是孤立事件，却因其是该市首次针对公众的毫无意义的恐怖行动而引人注目。虽然还不是贝鲁特的街道，但离那种疯狂又近了一大步。那种我们以为只潜伏在我们国界之外的疯狂。罗素街爆炸案和家庭法庭爆炸案被警方认为没有关联。但人们考虑过法院可能是目标。法院名单经过了核对，最近的判决也进行了审查，但没有发现任何异常。其他人认为这可能是一次恐怖袭击，称贝鲁特现在来到了澳大利亚。这种比较是因为当时正在进行的黎巴嫩内战，那里发生了许多爆炸事件。
But the obvious conclusion for most was that this was an attack against the police. The bomb had been put directly outside of police headquarters, and it had been set to go off at lunchtime, ensuring that a lot of police were going to be outside the building when the bomb exploded. After all of the initial confusion had settled, a direct attack against the police was how the case was treated. Although it was on fire and damaged, the bomb car wasn't completely destroyed, and something stood out. The chassis number had been drilled out. The chassis number being the serial number of a car used to identify it. The bombers had drilled through right across the chassis number, so you could no longer see it.
但对大多数人来说，显而易见的结论是，这是一次针对警察的袭击。炸弹被直接放在警察总部外，并被设定在午餐时间引爆，以确保炸弹爆炸时会有许多警察在建筑物外。在最初的混乱平息后，此案被视为针对警察的直接袭击。虽然炸弹车着火并受损，但并没有完全摧毁，有一点很突出。底盘编号被钻掉了。底盘编号是用于识别汽车的序列号。炸弹制造者钻穿了整个底盘编号，所以你再也看不到了。
This was very unusual, something the police hadn't seen before. The way criminals usually got rid of chassis numbers was to grind them down, or some would even try and change the numbers. Drilling through the chassis number completely was unique. Although it was completely pointless in this case, because the number plates had been left on the car. Maybe they thought the plates would be destroyed in the explosion, but they weren't, making the bomb car easily identifiable. It had been stolen two days before the bombing from the Brandon Park Shopping Centre in Mulgrave, which is about 20 kilometres or 12 miles away from Russell Street. A red and green coloured blanket was found inside the bomb car.
这非常不寻常，是警察以前从未见过的。罪犯通常销毁底盘编号的方法是将其磨掉，有些人甚至会尝试更改数字。完全钻穿底盘编号是独一无二的。尽管在这种情况下完全没有意义，因为车牌还留在车上。也许他们认为车牌会在爆炸中被摧毁，但并没有，这使得炸弹车很容易被识别。它是在爆炸发生前两天从穆尔格雷夫的布兰登公园购物中心被盗的，距离罗素街约20公里（12英里）。炸弹车内发现了一条红绿相间的毯子。
It was burnt and damaged, but it was in okay condition considering. Good enough to be forensically tested anyway, which was important, because the blanket didn't belong to the vehicle owner. He had never seen it before. An examination revealed it contained dog hairs, belonging to a bull terrier. This could be useful to match to a suspect's dog, if a suspect was ever identified. The car was checked for fingerprints using the super glue fuming method, not the dusting method. This is where super glue is combined with water, and the vapours react with chemicals in fingerprints. But no prints were found.
它被烧毁和损坏了，但考虑到情况，状况还算可以。至少足以进行法医鉴定，这很重要，因为毯子不属于车主。他以前从未见过它。检查显示毯子上含有狗毛，属于一只斗牛梗。如果能确定嫌疑人，这对于匹配嫌疑人的狗可能很有用。警方使用强力胶熏蒸法（而不是粉末法）检查了车上的指纹。这是将强力胶与水结合，蒸汽与指纹中的化学物质发生反应的方法。但没有发现指纹。
The search for evidence wasn't just restricted to the ground. Police from the Special Operations Group abseiled down buildings, hunting for evidence that had made its way up onto roofs and window ledges. It's on the roof of police headquarters that they found one of Constable Di Natio's boots. All of the pieces of shrapnel and all of the other evidence were bagged and taken to a large auditorium where they were catalogued. Twisted metal, bomb components, pieces of wire, the alarm clock and any other debris that was found. It was all bagged and treated with great care. The debris was basically treated like pieces of a large jigsaw puzzle that investigators would have to try and put back together. Any piece of the debris could contain valuable forensic evidence to help catch whoever was responsible.
搜寻证据不仅限于地面。特别行动小组的警察从建筑物上垂降，搜寻飞到屋顶和窗台上的证据。他们在警察总部的屋顶上发现了迪纳迪奥警员的一只靴子。所有的弹片和所有其他证据都被装袋，并带到一个大礼堂进行分类。扭曲的金属、炸弹组件、电线碎片、闹钟以及发现的任何其他碎片。一切都被装袋并小心处理。这些碎片基本上被当作大型拼图的碎片，调查人员必须设法将它们拼凑起来。任何碎片都可能包含有价值的法医证据，以帮助抓住肇事者。
To help with the cataloging, a large grid was placed over a map of the blast zone, and every piece of evidence was marked with a letter corresponding to where it was found on that grid. Five days after the explosion, Constable Di Natio was recovering from surgery, which had been successful. He was interviewed, but he wasn't able to assist with the investigation. He didn't see anyone or anything suspicious. Constable Angela Taylor was still in a critical condition and was fighting for her life. Although there were still no suspects, the investigation was coming along. Some of the debris from the blast had now been identified as being bread crates. Investigators had worked out the main part of the bomb had been placed onto a bread crate. Then the metal tools and sockets were placed on the crate around the bomb.
为了协助分类，在爆炸区域的地图上放置了一个大网格，每一件证据都标有字母，对应于它在网格上的发现位置。爆炸发生五天后，迪纳迪奥警员手术成功，正在康复中。他接受了采访，但无法协助调查。他没有看到任何可疑的人或事。安吉拉·泰勒警员仍处于危急状态，正在为生命而战。虽然还没有嫌疑人，但调查正在取得进展。爆炸中的一些碎片现在已被确认为面包板条箱。调查人员推断炸弹的主要部分被放置在一个面包板条箱上。然后金属工具和套筒被放置在板条箱上，围绕着炸弹。
And they knew where the bread crates came from. They were stolen during a robbery from a milk bar at Brayside, another suburb of Melbourne, about 26 kilometres or 16 miles southeast of Russell Street. The robbery occurred six weeks before the bombing. A large amount of cigarettes and confectionery were stolen along with the bread crates. There were no suspects for the robbery. A task force was established to investigate the bombing. It was made up of over 30 detectives, brought in from all different areas of Melbourne, making sure they were drawing on knowledge of possible suspects from across the entire city.
他们知道面包板条箱的来源。它们是在墨尔本另一个郊区布雷赛德的一家牛奶吧被抢劫时偷走的，距离罗素街约26公里（16英里）。抢劫发生在爆炸前六周。除了面包板条箱外，还偷走了大量的香烟和糖果。抢劫案没有嫌疑人。警方成立了一个特别工作组来调查爆炸案。它由来自墨尔本各地的30多名侦探组成，确保他们能够利用整个城市对可能嫌疑人的了解。
As well as local detectives, members from the Arson Squad, Major Crime Squad and Homicide Squad were called in to assist. They felt there weren't a lot of people that would be capable of the attack. There was one thing to hate the police. There was another level altogether to bomb police headquarters. It didn't take long for the task force to link the bombing to a break-in that occurred six months earlier, on the 6th of October 1985. A country mine was broken into near Blackwood, about 70 kilometres or 43 miles northwest of Melbourne. A large amount of detonators and gelling night were stolen, and those detonators and gelling night were used in the Russell Street bombing. There were no leads and no suspects for the break-in.
除了当地侦探外，纵火组、重案组和凶杀组的成员也被召集来协助。他们认为没有多少人有能力进行这种袭击。憎恨警察是一回事，炸毁警察总部则是完全不同的层面。特别工作组很快将爆炸案与六个月前，即1985年10月6日发生的一起入室盗窃案联系起来。墨尔本西北约70公里（43英里）处的布莱克伍德附近的一个乡村矿场被闯入。大量雷管和胶质炸药被盗，而这些雷管和胶质炸药被用于罗素街爆炸案。那起入室盗窃案没有线索，也没有嫌疑人。
The first lead for police happened when an unnamed male caller got in contact with the Victorian Police Commissioner. The caller said he knew who the bombers were, and he even had photos of them. He ended up calling in on five separate occasions, and he eventually said that he wanted US$500,000 in a Swiss bank account before he would tell police what he knew. The calls were traced to a number of public phone boxes in the St Kilda area, which is only a short distance away from Russell Street. Police weren't sure if the caller was genuine, or if it was just a hoax, but they couldn't ignore it. So the police commissioner was able to convince the government to offer a reward of $500,000. Not US dollars, and the money wouldn't be put in a Swiss bank account, but it was hoped it would be enough to entice the unknown caller to make contact again.
警方的第一个线索来自一名未透露姓名的男性拨打给维多利亚州警察局长的电话。打电话的人说他知道炸弹客是谁，甚至还有他们的照片。他最终打了五次电话，最后说他想要50万美元存入瑞士银行账户，才会告诉警方他所知道的情况。电话被追踪到圣基尔达地区的几个公用电话亭，距离罗素街只有很短的距离。警方不确定打电话的人是否真实，还是只是恶作剧，但他们不能忽视。因此，警察局长成功说服政府悬赏50万美元。不是美元，钱也不会存入瑞士银行账户，但希望这足以诱使那个不知名的人再次联系。
Premier John Kane and Chief Commissioner Mick Miller jointly announced the record $500,000 reward. But in a press conference, they refused to answer any questions on developments behind their decision. The offer of an amount of this magnitude might succeed in producing vital information. And I don't propose to divulge the nature of that information in case it might jeopardise this development. Police staked out phone boxes in the St Kilda area in the hope that the caller wouldn't be able to resist the huge reward. While waiting to hear from him again, police received hundreds of other calls from members of the public. Did it work? Find out next week in Part 2 of Russell Street, here on Case 4. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
州长约翰·凯恩和警察总长米克·米勒共同宣布了50万美元的创纪录悬赏。但在新闻发布会上，他们拒绝回答有关其决定背后进展的任何问题。“提供如此巨额的赏金可能会成功获得重要信息。我不打算透露这些信息的性质，以免危及这一进展。”警方在圣基尔达地区的电话亭蹲守，希望打电话的人无法抗拒巨额赏金。在等待他再次联系的同时，警方接到了数百个来自公众的电话。成功了吗？请在下周的《罗素街》第二部分中寻找答案，就在Case 4。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。